macaques love to monkey around here in
southern India when a peddler leaves a
fruit cart unattended for just a single
moment these bonnet macaques pounce on
alight hungry ants at a company picnic
those of you with very young children
will recognize this kind of eating
behavior so many peanuts so little time
then bananas well naturally oranges
basically whatever isn't nailed down and
if they can cry it up it's not nailed
out what a macaque doesn't eat on the
spot it puts in doggy bags called its
cheek pouches which it uses while
foraging for more food now it's on to
the next meal the bowl on the cats with
their distinctively long tails aren't
afraid to raid homes in search of food
and just an all-around good time now
grapes are always good full of fruit
sugar for the energy they'll need to
wreak havoc like a bunch of seven year
olds at an out-of-control birthday party
just when you think it can't get any
worse
it gets worse
they've been so destructive that the
Forest Service relocates them from the
city to a faraway forest but these very
social monkeys seem to take it in stride
and just turn this swimming hole into an
impromptu water park they're avid
swimmers and avid swingers and all this
swimming and swinging sure works up yeah
what else
a gigantic appetite no in life there's
what you know and what you don't know
and what you don't know you don't know
the maquettes know there's food here
what they don't know is that the guy who
set up this operation is making bootleg
liquor by fermenting fruit and what they
don't know they don't know is what
happens when a relatively tiny macaque
body encounters the kind of liquor that
can lay out a 200-pound human if
ignorance is bliss these macaques have
achieved euphoria
nothing left to do but try to sleep it
off